et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Bertrand pour cher bonjour merci d'être
avec nous député de la Meuse présidente
du célèbre goupillotte maintenant
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
et Bertrand pinchère demain sera donc
examiné en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale de votre proposition de loi
pour abroger la réforme des retraites
est-ce que vous pensez que la majorité
fera tout pour que le débat n'est pas
lieu
c'était d'ailleurs malheureusement le
cas depuis pratiquement le plus de dépôt
de ce texte de loi avec une accumulation
de de procédures d'exception qui prit
séparément peuvent se justifier mais je
rappelle quand même que la Constitution
selon générale de Gaulle c'est un esprit
des institutions et des comments et des
pratiques et le et le cumul des comment
le cumule des procédures de de
d'opposition à ce type de texte et
vraiment choquant
pour vous l'attitude de la majorité
choquante
il y a des moments je me demande même si
ils sont convaincus de ce qu'il raconte
quoi quand on se fait attaquer comme ça
sur l'article 40 alors que ça toujours
c'est à dire recevabilité financière
alors que ça a toujours été le cas
depuis le début de la 5e République on
se demande si enfin vraiment si si se
rendre compte de ce qu'ils disent
j'ajoute que bon les les conséquences
financières
enfin ce texte ce texte de loi notamment
dans le courant de l'année en cours
c'est à peine une centaine de millions
d'euros et c'est
ça cette accumulation la procédure nous
concernant et qui vise maintenant à
faire en sorte que la loi ne peut pas ne
pourrait pas être voté traduit sentiment
de panique généralisée du du
gouvernement et de la majorité relative
pourquoi panique mais panique parce que
d'abord ils ont pas gagné la bataille de
l'opinion publique
on a presque l'impression plus il
s'explique et il donne des détails sur
le texte plus il y a d'oppositions de
l'ensemble de nos commandes nos
concitoyens et à cette crise sociale
maintenant succès d'une crise
démocratique ils ont complètement les
pieds dans le les pieds dans le tapis
avec des Français médusés qui se
demandent à quoi servent les
institutions et le Parlement alors
justement on va écouter la réponse de
Yann Pivet est-ce que vous venez de dire
c'était il y a quelques minutes sur
France 2 on écoute la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale
j'entends même des gens dire ce serait
antidémocratique d'empêcher le vote on
entend ça j'ai envie de vous dire je
trouve ça dingue je trouve ça dingue
parce que c'est l'application de la loi
et de la règle et il n'y a rien de plus
démocratique que d'appliquer la loi si
on applique la loi il n'y aura pas de
vote sur ce texte on est d'accord mais
il ne doit pas y avoir de débat sur cet
article qui est clairement
anticonstitutionnel qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à la présidente de l'Assemblée
qui a dit exactement le contraire en
conférence des présidents il y a 15
jours je vais d'ailleurs souligner sa
grande dignité et on voit bien qu'elle
est mise en difficulté avec des
dépressions qui sont quand même assez
inavouables de sa commande sa
majoritaire relative elle a quand même
vraiment dit le contraire il y a 15
jours devant
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe il y
a un règlement à l'Assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on va pas pouvoir
revenir sur le règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale qui stipule que je le rappelle
depuis le début de la cinquième
république toutes les propositions
l'ensemble des propositions de loi n'est
pas soumises à cette cet article 40 sur
l'irosabilité
et par ailleurs il y a des procédures
qui ont été
comment qui ont été utilisés notamment
une surveillance de cette recevabilité
par les collègues du bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale et enfin il y a
des procédures de recours le recours
sépare le biais de de du président de la
commission Éric Coquerel qui va très
clairement expliquer que il y a pas de
sujet alors après que tout ça
anticipe des autres formes de blocage
c'est-à-dire notamment le rejet du texte
en commission pour faire en sorte qu'on
ne puisse pas le re-déposer par
amendement c'est peut-être là leur
stratégie et si c'est le cas c'est une
très très très grande gravité parce que
ça voudrait dire que demain seuls les
textes de la majorité quand on est
majorité pourrait être présenté avec des
incidences financières et pas les textes
de l'opposition
je sais pas si on se rend compte où on
marche quoi c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi j'avais dit que il faudrait
aussi qu'on puisse consulter le Conseil
constitutionnel dans une affaire comme
ça mais il y a le faire vous allez le
saisir on peut pas le faire comment on
peut pas le faire avant on peut pas le
faire avant la loi mais il faudrait
vraiment aussi disposer de l'éclairage
du Conseil constitutionnel qui qui qui
également est les Français doivent être
métis médusés quand ils voient tout ça
qui est également n'est même pas une
cour constitutionnelle c'est à dire
qu'on a une institut on a une
constitution où on passe son temps à
dans la boîte à outils tous les
obstructions puis début de la 5e
République on fait appel à un conseil
constitutionnel qui est pas une cour
constitutionnelle qui joue l'endroit
mais aussi en politique et après on se
demande pourquoi nos concitoyens ne
votent pas peur que le Conseil
constitutionnel rejette votre votre
démarche au titre de l'article 40
justement et ça serait quand même
intéressant que le Conseil
constitutionnel se prononce sur cette
forme de jurisprudence depuis le début
de la cinquième république j'ai quand
même depuis le début de la cinquième
République il y a quand même un petit
souci sur les finances vous disiez la la
réforme des retraites c'est une fontaine
de millions d'euros cette année mais à
terme c'est quand même 15 milliards
d'euros de
comment vous compensez ces 15 milliards
d'euros d'abord engageant sur les engage
sur les tabac ça veut dire que le prix
du paquet
une tartufferie va vous le savez tous
tout tous mieux que moi de de dire il
compense ça sur la taxe hôtel de
composer sur la taxe sur le terrain tout
le monde c'est nécessaire non non mais
je rappelle que c'est c'est c'est formel
on fait en sorte qu'on puisse présenter
un texte de façon équilibrée je rappelle
que 15 milliards je rappelle que d'abord
c'est pas 15 milliards maintenant 1 2 2
à terme c'est 15 2 économie par deux
deux il y a le débat sur les dépenses
que vont engendrer cette augmentation de
l'allongement de l'âge légal de duald
Trump quand il y a près 50% de chômeurs
qu'on va qui ce qui arrive à l'âge de la
retraite aujourd'hui quand on va encore
allongé deux ans toutes les études
disent que ça va nous coûter 6 à 7
milliards de plus si c'est milliards de
plus donc vous voyez comment vous voyez
bien c'est pas comment c'est pas
l'épaisseur d'un trait nous nous
expliquons qu'il faut évidemment faire
en pense que on équilibre notre régime
de retraite nous ne faisons par le biais
d'une conférence sociale et on nous dit
pas il y a pas de souci circulez il y a
rien à voir on fait confiance aux
commandes au dialogue au dialogue social
et j'ajoute et j'ajoute que la majorité
quand même un peu gonflé quand il y a
quelques semaines il nous présente un
texte dit bien vieillir pour mettre en
place des mesures en direction des
personnages ce texte est gageait par la
taxe sur le tabac non mais il se foutent
du monde quoi il y a 15 jours il vote le
truc et aujourd'hui nous dit c'est ainsi
constitution j'avais quand même que le
rapport Libo qui a été
qui était qui était réalisé en amont de
la PPL sur sur le texte bien vieillir
c'est à peu près 7 à 8 milliards d'euros
de dépenses supplémentaires et là il y a
rien à voir franchement comment comment
nos institutions sont respectées c'est
quand même ahurissant on va revenir sur
ce que vous avez dit parce que il y a
beaucoup de choses dans ce que vous nous
dites demain il y a l'examen en
commission qu'est-ce que vous ferez
est-ce que vous vous attendez déjà
est-ce que ça soit supprimé l'article
premier c'est-à-dire l'abrogation des 64
ans demain en commission
j'espère que ça sera pas le cas c'est
possible mais je vous dis c'est possible
mais j'espère que ça sera pas le cas
parce que si c'est le cas ceux qui se
prêterait à cette manoeuvre serait ceux
qui
joueraient de l'affaiblissement du
Parlement et vraisemblablement d'une
crise institutionnelle j'espère que
c'est pas le cas c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle j'ai pris ma plume
ce week-end pour écrire au président
Macron en lui rappelant que l'article 5
de la Constitution
faisait en sorte que il était le garant
de nos institutions et que l'article 3
de la Constitution
nous explique que la souveraineté
appartient au peuple et comment est
assez représentants et j'ai rajouté
d'ailleurs un troisième article de la
Constitution l'article 24 de la
Constitution qui prévoit que c'est le
Parlement qui vote les lois vous avez
une réponse
je lui écris je lui écris ce comment se
ce week-end en lui expliquant la gravité
de la situation de la situation si ça
arrive quand même vous faites quoi en
fait la question c'est
si ça arrive actuellement si ça arrive
on essaiera de redéposer un amendement
en comment un amendement qui comme le
laisse entendre Yaël Braun Pivet est
susceptible
d'entraîner un rejet dans le cadre de
l'article 40
je m'attends quand même à une une séance
relativement musclée j'attire votre
ascension également sur le fait que il y
aura une grosse manifestation le 6 juin
prochain c'est à dire deux jours avant
le texte de la loi j'attire également
votre attention sur les tous les leaders
syndicaux que nous avons reçu ces
derniers jours nous explique
les les Françaises et les Français sont
particulièrement désab usés et qu'il
faut une sortie de crise et ce texte est
une sortie de crise on va y venir mais
donc
imagine il y a pour une pivée sortent
l'article 40 en séance qu'est-ce que
vous faites est-ce que vous avez une
parade vous nous parliez tout à l'heure
d'un point du règlement vous allez
sortir quoi le règlement de l'Assemblée
qu'est-ce que vous faites si l'article
40 est dégagé
comment ça va se passer en commission
c'est le vrai sujet est-ce que le texte
passe lui comment oui ou non
comment en commission sia ou comment il
ressort s'il y a une impossibilité de
déposer notre propre
proposition de loi nous allons faire
remarquer que les droits de l'opposition
sont quand même complètement bafoués
puisque il y aura deux poids de mesure
maintenant ça veut dire c'est
l'acceptation que quand on est dans la
majorité on peut faire passer n'importe
quel type de loi et quand on est dans
l'opposition on est complètement
bâillonné donc on tirera on tirera
vis-à-vis
quelle manière qu'est-ce qui se passera
en séance est-ce qu'il peut ne pas y
avoir de séance le 8 juin c'est une
c'est une question et c'est une question
qu'il faut que je pose à mes collègues
je réunis les parlementaires de mon
groupe tout à l'heure on va
on va commencer à réfléchir sur comment
sur toutes les alternatives est-ce que
donc est-ce que dans ces conditions-là
nous allons continuer à discuter de nos
propositions de loi puisque nous en
avons d'autres évidemment qui suivent
est-ce que bon on va considérer que tout
ça est inacceptable et que il est dans
ces conditions
inutiles de comment de de sujet est-ce
que
certains disent nous y avons nous irons
sur une autre nous irons sur une autre
motion de censure je ne sais pas mais
vous savez quelques quelques jours avant
de déposer la motion de notre propre
émotion de censure mais mes collègues
parlementaires se posaient les mêmes
questions que je vous pose actuellement
nous on travaille
les députés indépendants
on analyse la situation
si on voit vraiment qu'il y a une très
très grave crise institutionnelle je
pense qu'on pourra pas rester comme ça
demain soir ne ressort pas comme vous
souhaitiez il se peut que vous ne le
discutiez pas le 8 juin
on va commencer ça fait partie
réellement des options tout tout va
dépendre de ce qui de reste dans cet ex
de loi vous en discuterai aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas encore tranché mais s'il
y a un blocage et pas de vote le 8 juin
vous êtes prêts à déposer une motion de
censure et vous pensez que dans le
contexte précis cette notion de censure
pourrait passer ça commence ça fait
partie comment ça fait partie pour nous
des hypothèses rien n'est comme on est
comment rien n'est soyez fédérer autour
de l'agacement de la communauté j'ai été
vraiment très très étonné de la façon
dont on a fédéré un nombre plus
important de parlementaire que ce que je
pensais lors d'une autre dernier de
notre dépôt de vous attendez je
m'attendais pas je m'attendais pas que
ça passe à nouveau après et là vous
pensez que dans le contexte les neuf
voix vous les vous pourriez les avoir
cette fois je ne comment je ne sais pas
enfin c'est des sujets
mes collègues des républicains un sujet
qu'il faut qu'ils se discute je pense
que si nous déposons un moment ou un
autre à nouveau une mention de censure
c'est cette fois-ci vous avez des
conversations cette fois-ci pour
renverser complètement le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qui fera que vous déposerez
une notion de censure précisément parce
qu'il peut faire qu'on dépose une motion
de censure c'est voir comment le
Parlement est humilié hein et deux
c'est aussi la perspective à mon avis
méchant discutera avec mes collègues de
faire en score meilleur que la dernière
fois c'est-à-dire la
bon sentir qu'on a vraiment une
possibilité cette fois-ci de renverser
le gouvernement donc ça dépend des
républicains puisque c'est ça dépend des
républicains ça dépend des républicains
évidemment d'ailleurs vous avez fait
plein et vous avez discuté avec les
républicains avec la ligne Pradier entre
je vois
je vois je vois tout le monde chez les
comment on républicains Aurélien Pradier
je croise évidemment régulièrement
c'est important pour nous de savoir quel
est l'état d'esprit des républicains
combien de parlementaires LR étant en
capacité de voter cette loi pour le
moment je ne le sais pas mais ça fait
partie que nous avons combien de
nombreux on me dit que il y a 25
parlementaires LR complètement hostile à
la loi qui en aurait beaucoup plus que
cela qui ne ferait pas le déplacement de
façon assez abstenir parce qu'on voit
bien les mêmes difficultés qu'ils ont
que nous dans nos circonscriptions même
si les miennes sont pas bon j'ai
beaucoup plus de soutiens que
d'opposition et on voit bien combien ça
va commencer à peu gêner un certain
nombre de députés LR qui
peut-être
n'auront pas non plus tous forcément
envie que cette loi parfois discuter lui
juin prochain
non juste sur la motion de censure vous
en avez déjà discuté avec les LR du
nouvelle motion de couture
de censure avec personne c'était on
s'était dit bon il va y en avoir
quelques-uns de l'air qui vont la
soutenir je crois qu'il y en a eu 19
enfin on parle des contacts que vous
auriez avec les députés et l'air mais en
face ce qui a des contacts entre des
membres du gouvernement des
représentants du gouvernement et un
certain nombre de vos députés qu'elle
est pressions qui se sont
énormément et de façon très très
choquante je vous le dis les yeux dans
les yeux très choquante des débauchages
individuels enfin heureusement que mes
parlementaires ont la tête solide y
compris d'ailleurs des menaces des
pressions sur leurs propres
circonscription sur lesquelles quel
début je il s'exprimeront comment il
s'exprimeront mais je vois l'exécuter
d'outre-mer on leur a expliqué que
c'était grave pour eux les députés
corses que la réforme constitutionnelle
se mettrait pas en place que mon
collègue dans le Nord avait des
difficultés avec ses usines et que le
gouvernement serait peut-être moins
actif enfin franchement c'était des
c'était des appels
au contraire moi j'avais des
parlementaires chez moi qui était
hésitant lors du vote de la motion de
censure ça c'est plutôt déclencher leur
voilà leur initiative donc et là il y a
eu encore dernièrement des députés enfin
des pressions sur mes amis corses
notamment par le président
du groupe horizon à l'Assemblée
nationale bon je peux vous dire qu'ils
ont ils ont balayé tout ça dans l'air de
la main
est-ce que vous-même vous avez eu des
coups de fil de la part de membres du
gouvernement non plus
j'en ai eu beaucoup beaucoup j'en ai un
peu de moi mais vous savez ça va revenir
parce que on est là on est en place on y
restera encore pendant 4 ans et donc bon
il y a pas d'autres alternatif que
travailler de travailler intelligemment
avec nous mais pour ça il faut changer
mais complètement de méthode qui rend
nous achète pas c'est pas à dire voilà
il y a un texte de loi qui arrive
qu'est-ce que vous en faites et si c'est
pas bien va négocier avec d'autres quoi
c'est c'est vraiment de la politique
politicienne moi je rêvais vraiment
qu'on puisse semer tous autour de la
table tous les groupes parlementaires
républicains de façon à nous engager se
mettre d'accord sur des grands projets
de société ces quatre premiers pour une
prochaine année on en a beaucoup nous
alors ce que vous décrivez se mettre
tous d'accord autour de la table c'est
ce que veut faire Gérald Darmanin sur le
texte immigration la proposition qu'il a
fait ce week-end dans le Parisien est-ce
que vous êtes prêt à discuter avec lui
avec le ministre du Travail et le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous avons été
reçus avec les deux ministres les
parlementaires et les parlementaires de
mon groupe
je lui ai dit nous j'ai dit aux deux
ministres que nous souhaitions vraiment
ce que ce texte reste équilibré on voit
bien que la version du gouvernement il
faut un texte équilibré on voit bien que
il faut essayer de réduire les
procédures mais franchement arrêtons de
dire qu'il y a des solutions miracles
passer à péter de rire quoi excusez-moi
quand on dit je suis allé voir un pays
la d'Europe un peu au nord qui a un pays
de 6 millions d'habitants et ça va mieux
se passer qu'en France enfin c'est on
est dans une crise migratoire qui est
vraiment la crise de la pauvreté la
crise de la violence bon et
ayant en même temps des centaines de
milliers de migrants sur notre
territoire qui sont là depuis 5 10 ans
qu'on expulsera jamais qui vivent dans
des toiles de tente de façon sordide je
vais vous donner un exemple moi pendant
la crise du covid pendant la crise du
covid on avait j'avais pris position
pour faire en sorte que on soigne
également les migrants dans dans un peu
les camps de rétention et j'ai passé
comme ça par le réseau des des migrants
pour quelqu'un qui était très comment
très attaché au droit des migrants j'ai
reçu en quelques jours de temps plus de
700 témoignages sur mon portable 700
témoignages sur mon portable je ne mens
pas j'ai cru qu'il me faisait des
copier-coller c'était tous des des
témoignages mais d'une violence enfin
c'était accablante de voir comment dans
quelles conditions et des femmes qui
étaient frappées qui pouvaient pas
déposer plainte j'ai eu le témoignage
d'une journaliste de vous confrère
algérienne qui était venu en France
suite à des violences violées depuis
plus 10 fois enfin c'est notre
territoire quoi enfin c'est d'abord des
femmes et des hommes et des enfants
j'aimerais d'abord bien qu'on commence
par appeler voilà ces personnes comme
des êtres humains en disant ben il faut
évidemment qu'on puisse renforcer les
conditions de sécurité et quand les
droits sont pas acquis qu'on puisse
juger plus facilement et qu'on puisse
évidemment renvoyer les personnes chez
eux c'est clair ça fait pas débat pour
nous mais en même temps il y a les
questions d'intégration et les questions
d'intégration par le travail moi qui
fait ma course à pied une fois par
semaine ou deux à Paris quand je les
vois dormir dans les toiles de tente
franchement vous pensez des propositions
des républicains qui veulent durcir la
politique migratoire qui veulent
notamment réformer l'aide médicale
d'État ou je les crois pas je pense que
comment je pense que c'est utile que les
républicains que vont réfléchissent et
fasse des propositions bon je pense que
il faut pas non plus mentir aux
Françaises et au vent français
en expliquant en expliquant qu'il y a
des solutions qui a des qui a des
solutions miracles je ne crois
d'ailleurs pas qu'ils le dise je peux
aimer bon mais faisons des propositions
des républicains vous êtes prêt à
soutenir
je me sens pour le moment très mal à
l'aise vis-à-vis de ce type de
proposition je vous le dis parce que je
ne crois pas que réduire les droits en
termes d'assistance médicale soit une
solution je ne crois pas que
diminuer enfin augmenter pardon les
délais de ces jours sur notre territoire
pour permettre à des migrants qu'on
expulsera jamais de travailler soit
comment soit une solution bon je pense
qu'il faut revenir je pense qu'il faut
revenir plus tôt pardon
proposer de sortir de l'Europe c'est pas
raisonnable pour qu'on dit ça on dit ça
parce que simplement
ça veut dire que il faudrait enfin on
accepte de ne pas juger les personnes
qui sont notre territoire simplement
parce que ils sont passés dans un autre
pays européen qui dispose les pas des
mêmes règles en termes d'immigration
tout ça c'est pas tout ça ne me semble
pas à la hauteur
une fois que la séquence réforme des
retraites sera terminée est-ce que votre
groupe va rester solide et comme le
groupe va se renforcer le groupe va se
renforcer et je vous le dis
le ce groupe parlementaire va être au
cœur de la recomposition politique on a
une liste aux Européennes et d'abord
notre ambition c'est d'être présent à
toutes les élections y compris les
élections européennes pour vous
présenterez
de notre pays à travers trois blocs
gouvernés ou dirigés par de même
populistes ou des césaristes pour je
pensais Emmanuel Macron on a besoin
d'une force des territoires une force
girondine d'écoute et je pense vraiment
que si nous ne le faisons pas dans
quatre ans c'est Marine Le Pen qui sera
au pouvoir donc conduite par qui nous
aurons soit une liste où seront présents
dans le débat pour le moment nous
testons dans le débat
si si
nous sommes présents dans le débat nous
nous rentrerons dans dans votre liste
mais il est clair que nous voulons nous
voulons comment nous voulons d'abord
nous discute chaque temps suffit sa
peine à la proposition de loi sur les
retraites ensuite nous avons créé une
propre association notre propre
association politique
utile avec un s à se tirer utile.fr j'ai
déjà en deux ans en deux mois de temps
plus de 500 adhérents on va sionner le
territoire pour structurer le territoire
nous nous sommes à l'écoute et nous
demandons maintenant à nos adhérents de
faire des propositions nous allons
travailler sur des propositions dans le
cadre des élections européennes pour une
Europe des territoires
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup
on regarde les lignes de Ouest-France
garant du crâne qui a fait une percée
cet été c'est à la Une de votre journal
Stéphane merci beaucoup on passe au club
des territoires